today's topic pj washington and
brittany jenner brittany renner my bad
if you aren't aware uh brittany renner
is a
is an insta-thought she's like you know
gotten it on with a bunch of basketball
players rich people she brags about it
and about a year and a half ago she got
with a young
nba player okay this young nba player
she's she's she's older than him
basically she got pregnant by him right
they were seeing each other they were in
a relationship they got married
apparently and he got her pregnant right
this happened in a very short span of
time and now he's gonna have to pay
child support supposedly she'd been
planning this divorce in secret before
he ever found out and uh plato's that
was a video that serviced resurfaced
about her saying that and be a pleasure
are dumb hold up let me replace
something it didn't resurface that [ __ ]
was viral the first time she said it
this girl was literally used as a
quintessential example of why you
shouldn't mess with instagram thoughts
it's not like this was a hidden secret
mm-hmm
everybody knew you're talking about
viewers that were out two years four or
five years ago
so anyways i'll play the video for you
guys this is her well before this
relationship talking about who she gets
with i want to know my body count i
don't know why in like 2018 that's any
of your
business
or why it matters
but 24
11 athletes
five entertainers
eight
regular guys
i've only three regular guys since i've
been instagram famous because a lot of
y'all run your mouse too much i don't
want to be sending you a video
one minute the next minute i see me
spread eagle on the timeline playing
with my
in my experience the worst people to
deal with are the athletes none of them
use condoms really so if y'all really
want to try to come up off a check off a
man you could just an athlete they're
really done
i don't like talking about my history
with men i'm dating so i'm going to just
stop it there and continue in a little
bit i don't feel bad for the young
brother
evidence was out there people warned you
you ignored it
you pay pay you get what you get
you know
so many people
like to keep track of all the men that
i've been with
it makes you wonder
why are you concerned unless you
would want to be one of these
anger
about what you can't have
now any man would be lucky to have me
that's why
a lot of them still check for me
i'm just sick and tired of wearing
panties
so much so said i stole them
or
away
what's wrong daddy
which one do i tell y'all out here
getting the wrong woman pregnant then
you complain it's one thing if she hides
everything about herself and that
happens sometimes
they devious this girl got video
evidence of her talking about how stupid
you are and you do the exact dumb [ __ ]
is she lying is she wrong
i mean she's gonna do what she does
that's a waste of time okay
there's always gonna be jezebel's out
there it's gonna happen on this is on
you
to protect yourself
is that victim blaming call it whatever
you want i live in a world where there
are people who do really bad [ __ ] on
purpose but when they advertise it
like my first
instinct is to telling
you should have known
but
you already knew
let me ask you ask me
you go to the zoo i go to the zoo it
says
beware do not cross barrier do not cross
the barrier because you cross a barrier
and i get mauled by a bear do i feel bad
no of course not die natural selection
if you're that much of a
idiot where there's a sign that says
danger danger yeah
they sent it to your inbox they showed
you the evidence of someone else getting
married it's right there and you still
jumped in we wouldn't feel bad no but i
can't say this stuff and say you're an
idiot pj washington without people
saying oh victim play what no what are
we talking about right now today's video
is sponsored oh wait
all right you already know
okay we're ready today's video is
sponsored by bluechu say it with us now
blue chips it's time for you to gain
more confidence and longer lasting
experiences in the bedroom with
bluetooth tablets okay you deserve
better she deserves harder get it
together
bars listen blue chew is a unique online
service that offers you
the same active ingredients as a viagra
in cialis but in a chewable form and at
a fraction of the cost and one of the
best parts is that you know blue chew
it's an online service so you don't need
to go to the doctor and have an awkward
conversation with that person all you
gotta do is go to bluetooth.com you just
need to consult with one of their
medical licensed professionals and once
you're approved we just ship it to your
door and we got a special deal just for
you guys you can try bluetooth for free
when you use promo code abba all right
and all you gotta do is pay for the five
dollar shipping that's bluechew.com
using promo code abba and get your first
month free so a big shout out to
bluetooth for sponsoring this video
listen hypothetical mart let me play
devil's advocate maybe pj washington has
never had good role models maybe he's
had never had some man to hold his hand
with that
i'm sorry i'm sorry right so maybe
because of that
he didn't develop the good judgment when
it came to him because he had nobody to
put him on game if you've been a simple
your whole life you have no good male
role models you might still be a simp
even if people tell you otherwise
because you're like oh we being magical
maybe fair but at the end of the day
it's still your responsibility brother
all right so now you're going to learn a
20 million dollar lesson very expensive
but it is what it is 20 million dollars
plus 200 projected mine projected
projected yeah and you might make way
more so you know it's just one of those
things that i'm like
what did you expect she got her bang
200 000 a month is a lot of [ __ ]
money
yeah for
having a nice ass
it'll get you very far that's that
female privilege what are we crazy
what do we place that
who plays that high on the tier right
what beauty privilege yeah i put it i
put a s here
i put a s t my man listen being a
beautiful woman you could make your
whole destiny if you wanted to yeah
much more than if you were a beautiful
man
sure i agree most of the guys that i've
dealt with are gonna have more money
than you
and you're gonna feel a way about it i
know the male ego is fragile like the
ball sack that hangs in between your
legs in conclusion like i don't even
look at people as like trashy or not it
all comes down to mentality for me hey
man she proved the point
anybody that was trashing her she proved
the point listen that's the part
i wish she was wrong
i wish she was wrong she got her back
this information age the fact that you
don't look this stuff up or research
your partner especially if they're a
public figure sorry that's a big mistake
on your part got to make better
decisions everybody got to be smarter
got to be better about the money but let
this be a lesson to you guys
about the people you're with
and when they show you who they are
believe them
this girl told you what it is she
thought you're an idiot
you are
you're a dumb [ __ ] and it's
gonna cost you a lot of money so you
know it is what it is
that's my thoughts on that whole thing
uh as far as she's concerned abby what
do you think about her
hey man jezebels are going to be out
here
she's like asking me what i think about
a murderer i was like they gonna murder
you know what i mean it is what it is
she hustles can't speak to that person
of the population i don't bother i'm not
a i'm not somebody who can save people
as far as commentary like
i don't know she told you who she was
she's not alive she got integrity at the
very least
she told you what it is on display
she manipulated me no
maybe i don't know i don't know i don't
know how you got manipulated by that
this fake ass and you got her bruh this
steak has poison in it you eat the steak
and then you go
in the toilet and then you'll be like oh
my god
oh my god this thing was bad all i'm
gonna say
pj on display hold on say pj get in that
gym
start shooting
you're gonna need to keep up the child
support payments you better stay in
shape you better pray there's no
injuries you better pray you stay on top
that's all i'm gonna say anything else
all right
that's it for today's video let us know
what you guys think in the comments
below do you guys agree was i too rough
was i too mean i don't know i just i
want you guys to make better decisions
for yourself so don't
learn from this learn from this man all
right anything else
all right
that damn
[Music]
foreign